[Music]
all right let's go to andrew in
charlotte hey andrew what's up man
dr john how you doing man i'm all right
brother how are you
uh it's a good day because i'm talking
to dr john deloney so it's a better day
because i'm talking to andrew man so
what's up how can i help
so here's the thing i'm a recovering
alcoholic okay and i i'm having some
struggles and
i kind of the best way i guess i can put
it is i kind of feel like brooksy from
shawshank redemption you know what i'm
talking about like yeah struggling with
life on the outside yeah um and you know
this life after sobriety and
um how long have you been in particular
uh about 22 months 22 months are you are
you in a program of any kind
yeah i joined aaa still going to
meetings okay
yep is that is that working for you
you know it has been um
i got to be honest though lately
i don't know if it's you know the group
i'm in the area that i'm in i've become
a little disenfranchised um
and yeah i know a lot of that's on me
but it just kind of feels like i'm not
it just feels like for the last
maybe year i've been kind of you know
talking around in circles and
talking to the same people telling the
same stories
and i i kind of feel that i've hit a rut
and like i'm stuck and not moving
forward what are you doing differently
um
i started being a little more relational
with people kind of
outside of the program and trying to get
in touch with
uh
what it means to be a friend and and to
use the people around me that care about
me so something i've been doing
different lately is you know more
one-on-one
chats with people that i trust okay um
which um you know that that's been a
good that's been a good change
so you're um you're married right
yeah yeah kids
yeah we got two kids how's that going
um man it's been so great to reconnect
with my boys um they're two and four
awesome and yeah and that that's been
that's been really good but you know
what i'm struggling with is you know i
i drank heavily for a long time
i i started young
um i was a i was a professional musician
and very much lived kind of
stereotypical lifestyle yeah and um
about 18 years of drinking from the age
of like 17 to 35.
and
i i kind of feel like i woke up
from an 18-year coma
and i've been dropped into the middle of
this battle zone
naked with no gun
and i kind of realized dude i don't know
how to be a husband how to be a father
it's how to be a man
and and i i feel kind of stuck in this
adolescence and it's it's been
it's been kind of frustrating and where
i struggle with most
because my issues are bound but where i
struggle with most is i'm trying to make
things right with my wife because nobody
suffered
more than her
and
it's been so hard you know this this
recovery process just hasn't been
i i haven't made the progress
that i need to make
um you know
what do you think what do you think
progress is
it's
it's complete openness okay um honesty
and humility are you still lying to her
no
you still lying to your boys
i'm not lying to my boys who are you
lying to
i'm doing a lot of lying to
i i guess to
i guess to me
well what about
i i i don't
i listen to these voices in my head
i am not
i'm never going to make this right that
you know this things are never going to
change and you know what dude you just
need to bail
and i'm fighting with that voice yeah
that voice is real man yeah and that
voice has earned its seat at your table
and at some point
that you'll you'll look over one day and
see that that
voice just mouthing but you won't hear
the words anymore but right now it's
loud right
what do you think
paint me a picture brother of what
quote-unquote making things right looks
like
how do you get back 18 years with the
woman you love
like what is that what do you think that
even looks like
when
when we can reach a point where she sees
me
as her leader
as her provider
because right now i just i don't think
she feels safe she doesn't feel secure
she doesn't feel what makes you think
that
uh well apart from her saying as much
i mean that's the best answer ever
because you said it
yeah uh and and i i see it i see it in
her frustration um you know even when
she doesn't say it yeah
um
how long have you all been together
uh
seven years okay yeah yeah you've been
drinking for 18 years but y'all been
together for seven years
yeah um
does this woman love you
she must man because
no no no no no no that was bullcrap
answer does she love you
she does love me yeah she does
yeah so two things i see here
number one
everyone in the world can forgive andrew
but if andrew doesn't forgive andrew
this whole thing ends in a dumpster fire
and until andrew forgives andrew you go
around in trying to perform for people
right it's like you went like you're a
musician right what'd you play
was a guitar player okay you're a
guitarist and one night you botch the
solo
you are so hell-bent on making sure we
play that sold to the next night so i
can redo it right and you can't wait to
go back to that town because you're
going to let them have it the next time
right you're going to really
relationships don't work like that man
and you're running around trying to
perform for people which you feel like
is connection because you're seeing
people for the first time but people who
are being performed for you're not
connecting with him at all
so last night i uh a buddy of mine
um called
and he said he was heartbroken he said
hey i my wife just had a birthday party
and she told me i just wanted to be
chill and want to go to dinner but i
wasn't going to do that
i threw a massive thing i threw a i
planned everything i started with
breakfast in the morning i made it a big
old deal and by the time evening rolled
around they were in a big fight
and he called me and was like can you
like what did i do man like i did this
and this and this and this and this
and she said i wasn't listening to her i
couldn't see her i couldn't hear
and i i was quiet and i was like brother
you threw a party
for your wife you used your wife as a
tool for you to get accolades for
yourself
and you used your wife
as means by which you could throw
something really great so that you her
and other people around could tell you
how great you were
and so you didn't listen to your wife
who gave you exactly what she wanted
which was i just want a small chill
thing
and
you did something that you wanted to do
in order to
make yourself feel better
and he was like oh crap you're exactly
right i just wanted her to have a great
party and i was like
then you should have do something
something low-key like she said
and where you are right now is very
similar
my guess is
safety for your wife looks like
you being calm and chill and making
coffee in the morning taking the trash
out
and making the bed and saying good
morning i love you
and can we have a hug
and you taking the boys for walks
and
when you are trying to prove leadership
status or provider status
dude she doesn't need a leader and a
provider she's been that she needs a
co-pilot
she needs somebody with her not over her
does that make sense
yeah totally man and the language is
important here
because if you walk up to her and be
like i just want to be your leader she's
going to look at you and go bro i've
been leading this thing for seven years
now i'm good
she probably just wants you to love her
and you can't do that until you forgive
andrew
why don't you love andrew enough to
forgive andrew
oh man
you know it feels it
i really hate the things that i've done
and i guess i keep
dwelling on that i can dwell on stuff
with the best of them that's right
that's right hey you just said it
perfect though
you have a pin in your hand
uh i've got a keyboard okay
i want you to type
a period on that keyboard just type it
one dot
done
you said the things i've done period
past tense over
there are zero things you can do about
those things
none
you cannot edit those sentences they're
done
the only thing you can do is write new
ones or you can just keep reading the
old ones over and over and over and over
and especially for people working
through sobriety but for all of us
ruminating thoughts just letting those
suckers spin feel so good man it feels
like we're doing
heavy lifting
it's it's not man it's a complete burn
of
social and spiritual energy
and what i'm telling you do is quit
reading the old sentences you can change
zero of those things none
what you can change is how much you love
those boys you can make meaning of the
last 20 years
and have these one-on-one conversations
with people who are one two five ten
years ahead of you on this journey who
really know how to love their wives
really know how to be great dads and
they can teach you and you can call them
and you can text them on the mornings
you wake up and say dude my
four-year-old and two-year-old if i hear
one more thing about bluey or
if i have to change one more diaper or
if my kid pees all over the bathroom one
more time i'm gonna set the house on
fire and they'll send you some funny
emoji back or whatever you gotta have
those guys in your life but they're
gonna walk alongside and provide a
picture for what marriage looks like
that you don't have provide picture for
a parent or that you don't have
man that's where you're at
you cannot change the done things period
and so after this call i want you to
the one challenge i have with aa i love
that it connects people together i love
it with all my heart i love that it
gives structure to people i love that it
pushes people outside of the things
that they can see with their hands the
scientific part and says man you gotta
surrender to something bigger than you i
love all that stuff
i love the talking and talking and
talking the honesty and the
vulnerability i love it the one thing i
don't love about it is the identity that
i am and will always be this
that's my one but beef with it because i
think you can change
and it starts with forgiveness of
yourself and it starts with reconnecting
has your wife told you what she needs
from you
yeah she has what she said
well the the basic thing was
stop lying start communicating
that was the headline and communication
and letting her in yeah that's what she
needs so here's what we're gonna do
starting today you ready
yeah i'm ready
i want you to do three things together
number one
every day i want you to start and end
every day with skin on skin contact
usually by holding her hands and looking
her in the eye and this is gonna sound
cheesy tell her some idiot on the radio
told you to do this okay and i just want
you to stare at her into her eyeballs
for 10 to 30 seconds while holding your
hands that's it say nothing
now brother you're communicating
you're not transferring info
you're not giving her a bunch of facts a
bunch of data you're communicating
okay this is connection
all right the second thing is i want you
to ask her what does your picture for
today look like just today
and not hey what are you gonna do today
well i'm gonna i'm gonna do this
what's your picture today look like
what does peace and laughter and
forgiveness enjoy and what does that
look like today
and let her speak into your life and
then you answer with awesome
i'll do what i can to help make that
happen period conversation's over
okay the third thing is i want you all
to begin to do a gratitude journal in
the morning and evening together
and so what you're asking for her of her
is five minutes a day
and the gratitude journal is gonna be a
single journal you all keep on your bed
that's just gonna be something you'll do
together which is i'm grateful for
five in the morning five in the evening
before you go to sleep
okay
that's it
that's it
and when she tells you something no
rebuttals no but yeah but this
no none of that
if it sets off your body and you can
feel it in your chest and you can feel
it like oh i'm starting to feel the
shame i'm starting to feel the crazy you
take that stuff to your sponsor you take
that stuff to these one-on-one
conversations you're having with people
but right now you're learning you're
teaching your wife that you are a safe
place you're not gonna lie you're not
going to give rebuttals you're not going
to be like well you should be doing it
none of that stuff
you're safe and what's going to happen
in short order i'm talking like 30 60 90
days her alarm systems are going to go
are going to start tuning way down
she's gonna when she when you're around
and you're looking her in the eye
her heart rate's not gonna take off on
her
her brain's not gonna start spinning and
when her stops doing that then yours
stops doing that because we're
co-regulated and our heartbeats match
the person in front of us when we're
stressed
and you're going to see a general
temperature gumming that coming down in
your home
and every single day by the way you're
going to hold your little boys and
you're going to hold your their their
face in your hands and you're going to
look them in the eye and you're going to
make silly faces but you're going to
touch them on the face and when they say
say nope this happens every day you're
going to tell me you love them
and every time something comes up from
your past that you remember
you're going to say the words out loud
nope
not going there
because you can't do anything about it
oh my gosh that one time i said i was
going to come home and i didn't show up
and i ended up on a bus but nope
that's it i'm out so i'm stopping it
right
this is you slowly retaking control of
two important things your thoughts
and your actions and by the way dude you
got to have a workout program you got to
you got to you got to start exercising
you got to start eating right these are
the baseline stuff right
andrew 100 you can get there so here's
what i need you to do after 30 days of
this skin to skin contact twice a day
gratitude journal today twice a day
asking your wife what does today look
like for you
30 days i want you to holler back at me
and if you say like this thing sucks we
did this this is you're an idiot deloney
i will announce this on this radio show
million people listen
i almost guarantee it's not going to
okay guarantee it's not going to thank
you so so much for your bravery brother
i have a hundred percent confidence in
you
and if it makes you feel better um
you're right where you need to be you're
right where you need to be it's gonna be
hard two years in hang in there hang in
there hang in there brother andrew thank
you so so much for that call